so there's a new Dragon Age Inquisition
trailer yeah we can't actually show the
trailer in its entirety but we can talk
about it the fat cats over a biological
warehouse can't stop yeah as a noted
Dragon Age expert yourself I'm sure you
picked up on some details in this trip
so that maybe the rest of us didn't so
there's not a whole lot to talk about in
the sense that it's a typical video game
trailer you know dragons and magic and
swords and and all that stuff but there
are a few things to note for example we
see you know on a snowy hill top hey
look this could be the Inquisition's
headquarters up here and and you know we
know the game was going to take place
across four eldon or lay so it makes
sense of course the Inquisitor would
make a make a spot in fur Alden to call
home but so so we do get to see a
glimpse of that and we know of course
that you play the Inquisitor and there
are there are several references to the
role of religion in the Dragon Age
universe throughout one is of course the
idea that you know you have power
because in essence the people think that
you've been given power by the maker
that is God in the Dragon Age universe
where the dragons aren't gods this is
not not this time okay no but I do know
that when it comes to dragons in this
game supposedly at least we've been told
that every dragon fight will be unique
from a gameplay perspective so that'll
be interesting at first in dragons at a
bit of a key driver
kind of a drag kind of a drag the dragon
yeah there were it depends on how you
sort of handle it there were
possibilities of more than one but I
don't think you had to fight more than
one if i recall correctly it's been a
while though since dragon age origins
came out but then we see later on to
hear some voiceover regarding you know
the how religion is used as a tool for
war and Haworth we're fighting over you
know this this whole imaginary being
thing and that's that's some pretty
harsh harsh stuff coming from you know
coming from dragon age trying to be
trying to be a little on the nose with
current events and things like that I
would say yeah but then but then of
course we do see all the fighting and we
see the dragon in the one cool spot
where the dragon like snatches the dude
up and munches down I would imagine as
yeah as dragons do and towards the end
we get to see of course the you know all
the possible party members behind the
Inquisitor yeah one particular returning
here one returning character in the form
of Erik Erik with his luxurious chest
hair yeah he's always no other way he's
always pretty great he's he's probably
the best-looking dwarf outside of that
dude from The Hobbit who falls in love
with the elf so there are other
returning characters besides just hot
dwarves or is it dwarfs I always forget
dwarves dwarfs force um but yeah but
there are other returning characters
even though they may not be in your
party like Liliana is returning and
she's going to be you know she's gonna
be helping you with the Inquisition
she's an officer in the Inquisition so
that'll be really good Liliana returning
but outside of that there's not a whole
lot knew that we get from the trailer
it's more of a you know setting the
stage it's more of an atmosphere type
trailer but you know I'm actually kind
of excited I mean it starts in snow and
we know that I'm a big snow dude when it
comes to I do love snow and video games
so this will be looking forward to it
November can't come soon enough more
dragon age let's see
you